I've had so many things going through my
head
what do I do
a story right out of a nightmare a
Mesquite woman robbed and then kidnapped
while working the graveyard shift at a
Terrible's thank you for joining us here
at six o'clock I'm Denise feldes and I'm
Brian Loftus Brandi Perry sharing her
story now exclusively with Victoria Saha
who is joining us live in studio and
Victoria Brandy told you she leaves and
wants others to really learn from what
she went through yeah that's right that
was the biggest reason for her sitting
down with me is to show she is stronger
than the crimes that were committed
against her and while I did sit down
with her listening to her recount the
details of her ordeal it truly felt like
you were reliving this with her
oh I can't think it was I need to save
my life too afraid to return back home
to Mesquite Brandy Perry speaks with me
while staying with family in Las Vegas
Perry is the manager at terrible Herb's
convenience store in Mesquite she
describes her graveyard shift as usually
slow with occasional regular customers
stopping in but the early morning hours
of July 24th would be a shift she'd
never forget I noticed he was standing
there next to my Krispy Kreme
spot eating a donut the man Perry is
referring to is Who police say is
34-year-old Kyle Lewis dines and he said
I'm sorry but you need to give me your
Epping money at this moment Perry is
doing everything dines is asking her to
do I opened it up took everything out
that I had in it
and when he pulled out his bag
his gun came up and that's when I knew
it was my fight or flight but little did
Perry know this wasn't going to end as
just a robbery by the time I got all of
the money in his bag he told me he was
like you need to come with me Perry says
dines forced her to leave the store and
get into a car I was thinking he didn't
want to leave a witness
because of how agitated he was
I thought I was good as Dead all I kept
telling him was you know I have kids I
have grandkids I'm I'm human Perry
eventually convinces dines to let her
out of the car before he got onto the
15. I'm thinking he's gonna come back
he's he
too
regret letting him go and he's going to
come back and he's going to finish me
that is when Perry quickly called 9-1-1
and ran to Casablanca Resort do you
think it helped that you kept reminding
of him that
who you are as a person I think
humanizing myself made it harder for him
to harm me in any way though it's only
been a few days since the incident Perry
says she is determined to be known as a
Survivor not a victim you may have made
me
scared you may have gave me PTSD
but I'm strong
no I'm not let him
get my life my life is mine and I'm
going to take it back
Mesquite police say they arrested dines
later that day and they also arrested
four other people you can see them right
here on your screen we're told they're
all involved in a string of crimes
charges ranged from Felony kidnapping to
conspiracy to robbery with a deadly
weapon